foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're discussing the
tri-wizard tournament the trial was a
tournament was one of the deadliest
competitions in the entire Wizarding
World with a death toll that Rivals the
professional dueling Arenas in Eastern
Europe the Triwizard Tournament was
actually pretty barbaric it's baffling
why Hogwarts and its fellow schools kept
it going for so many centuries but what
made it so dangerous and how did it get
started in the first place we'll answer
those questions and More in today's
video Origins nobody's quite sure when
the first trial wizard tournament came
to be just like most events from the
early Wizarding World the first try was
a tournament's Origins are all but lost
to time but based on a little bit of
information we still possess from that
era we can build a rough picture of the
earliest tournaments Hogwarts of course
was founded by godric Gryffindor and his
three Wizarding friends in the latter
half of the 11th century and only about
two centuries after that the very first
Triwizard Tournament debuted the dates
are a bit fuzzy but sometime around the
year 1294 the three major Wizarding
schools of the region The durmstrang
Institute and the bobotal Academy of
magic and came together and decided to
pit their students against each other
and quidditch was already a popular
sport by this time and had pushed
rivalry between different magical
settlements to new highs so the creation
of the Triwizard Tournament was a
natural next step in a world where
Wizards from different regions regularly
competed against each other the schools
you already know that Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry was one of these
prominent European schools but the trial
was a tournament was rounded out by two
others the durmstrand Institute and
bobatole Academy of magic while Hogwarts
mostly accepted British and Irish
students The durmstrang Institute took
its pupils from all over Europe located
in a mysterious part of the continent
far into the north The durmstrang
Institute always seemed to produce
Wizards and witches who wouldn't shy
away from a fight the students at
durmstrang were even well versed in the
dark arts unlike Hogwarts who only
taught children how to defend against
dark Wizards and curses The Faculty at
dumbstrang actually instructed its
pupils on how to use dark magic perhaps
that is why Gaelic Grindelwald the
infamous dark wizard of the early 20th
century became so infatuated with the
dark arts in the first place the third
competitor in the trial was a tournament
must always hail from The bobatal
Academy of magic this magical school was
unsurprisingly e located in France but
unlike the film it wasn't a girl's only
School plenty of famous Wizards attended
bovatore Academy in fact the greatest
Alchemist of the modern era Nicola
Flamel attended bobert Hall as you know
he was The Wizard who created the
Philosopher's Stone the very first item
that Lord Voldemort sawed after binding
his body to Professor Quarles the
children at bobato were quite easy to
spot in a crowd especially during the
tournaments compared to the
gruff-looking students from damstrang
and the motley crew of kids at Hogwarts
those from bobato were typically
elegantly dressed and well composed in
public but their preoccupation with
their appearance didn't mean that they
slouched in the classroom students at
bobator were absolutely great Wizards
and witches truth be told they possessed
nearly as many try wizard victories as
Hogwarts and only needed one more to
make it a tie history ever since the
tournament began in the late 13th
century it plugged along becoming a
staple in the lives of many Wizarding
students throughout Europe and Britain
the three schools pledged to hold the
event every five years and for the most
part they stuck to that but even though
the tournament played such an important
role in the history of magical education
you might be surprised to know that
there aren't many records about the
games or even the champions from each
tournament in fact much like other murky
histories in The Wizarding World we only
know a bit about the trial as a
tournament of the Middle Ages until it
was put on a Hiatus in the 1790s
Hogwarts durmstrang and bobator
participated in at the very minimum
125 tournaments and by the time Harry
Potter had a shot at the Goblet Hogwarts
held 63 Victors and boba commanded a
very convincing second place seed with
62 wins of their own it's hard to know
exactly what happened during those
centuries but if you think about it the
games must have been downright scary
after all during Harry Potter's own
trial was a tournament in the early
1990s Albus Dumbledore and the other
Headmasters made sure to reduce The
lethality of the events they didn't want
any more deaths on their hands but the
try was a tournament from the distant
past and a bloody reputation for killing
maiming and crippling their participants
the types of tasks Harry faced during
his tournament like taking on a
Hungarian horntail Dragon might have
been a walk in the park compared to some
of the ones previous generations faced
it wouldn't be far-fetched to speculate
that truly dark beasts like Dementors or
leatherfolds were Unleashed during the
games but in the end we'll never know
the full truth all we know is that the
games were canceled towards the end of
the 18th century or the beginning of the
19th there had been far too many deaths
and the parents of children at Hogwarts
refused to let their kids be fodder for
entertainment anymore it was a
cockatrice the horrid rooster and lizard
hybrid which might have been the straw
that broke the camel's back during a
tournament in the 1790s one of the
magical beasts a cockatrice broke free
from the game field during its
subsequent Rampage the Headmasters of
each School fell victim and was savagely
attacked if it wasn't for an odd comment
that Hagrid once made when he implied
that he had been alive during a Triumph
was a tournament that game involving the
cockatries might have been the very last
one perhaps rubius was letting us in on
a secret that there had been a few
failed attempts to bring the Triwizard
Tournament back over the years but it
didn't come back in full force until
Harry Potter's fourth year at Hogwarts
during that game Albus Dumbledore and
the other Headmasters tried their best
to reduce the violence in the games
but in the end yet another student lost
their life this time it wasn't exactly
the tournament's fault though Lord
Voldemort and his Lackey Barty Crouch Jr
had used the games to lure Harry Potter
into a dark ritual where Voldemort would
regain a true physical body in the
process Cedric Diggory was murdered by
Peter Pettigrew a small casualty in
Voldemort's ultimate plan to regain
power rules now if you're unfamiliar
with the rules of the trial was
atonement you're in luck because they're
pretty straightforward every tournament
had three games typically tournaments
wouldn't reuse the same games or
challenges year after year but after so
many centuries of competition you'd be
surprised just how hard it was to
concoct new challenges for the students
so three challenges would be drafted and
the head of each school would judge the
Champions on their ability to complete
each one in the past the tournament was
open to almost anyone as long as they
were a current student at one of the
three schools but by Harry Potter's time
a few careful changes were drafted in
order to prevent younger year students
from losing their lives the most
important alteration was an age charm
that prevented anyone younger than 17
from placing their name in The Goblet oh
yeah and about the Goblet of Fire the
giant cup filled with blue flames was
just like the Sorting Hat students would
submit their names into the flames and
the Goblet would consider each one until
it selected the perfect Champion for
each school on the last day of October
Halloween the cup would make its
selection known from that point on the
champions of each School were entered
into a magical contract were forced to
compete in the tournament or else in the
end whoever performed the best and so
survived would not only win the
tri-wizard camp but also 1 000 galleons
to spend as they pleased Legacy by the
time Harry Potter participated in the
trial was a tournament it had been
centuries since a proper version of the
games were held most of the Wizarding
World hoped to see the game's return as
a way to celebrate magical excellence in
their young wizards but with Cedric
diggory's tragic death the tournament
was dealt its final blow five years
later long after Voldemort's death the
next try was a tournament failed to
appear and as far as anyone knows it's
canceled permanently honestly after the
battle of Hogwarts and all of those
senseless deaths I think the Wizarding
World is fine without the tournament
young Wizards and witches from Britain
don't really need to prove their courage
or metal in pointless games they already
showed how tough they are in the final
fight against Lord Voldemort
and that's it for this video do you have
anything to add about the try wizard
tournament got any questions leave them
in the comment section down below until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]